διαφορε λόγιόπως επήρόπως επίσης υπάρχουν και διάφοροι λόγι που δημειουργείται οι μετάλλαξη ενός καλοηθούς κιτάρουν
σε κακοήθες δηλαδή αλλάζει τον διενέη του και του δημειουργί τα χαρακτηριστικά της κακοήθειας ι
τα χαρακτηριστικά της ι μετάλλαξη μπορεί να διμουργηθεί είναι ακόμα και από την φυσική ακτυνογολί
αντην οποία δεχόμαστε από διάφορες στο ξεοκεισουσίες από διάφορα μηχανικά προβλήματα ελα οποία υπάρουν υπάρχουν
διάφοροι λόγι που δημιουργούνται οη μεταλλάξεις δί βλέπεται ότι δεν είναι μόνον είναι διάφορο η
λόγι που δημιουργούνται οι μεταλλάξεις και διάφορει λόγι που από το μας απογοητεύει το ανοσωποητικό
υ μας σύστημα και δεν αναγνωρίζει την κακοήθεια για τρέστεη ζωή σας είναι μεταξύ κύπρου
καιελλάδος διάφέρει πολύ το σύστημα ηγίας των δύοχώρο όπως δήποτε διαφέρει καιο ίναι το καλύτερο
φυσικά ταο κυπριακό είναι καλύτερο ον κυπρινα το κυπριακό δε χρειάζεται διαδή στο εληνικό σύστημα
υπάρχουν διάφορες υπάρχουν διάφορες αδυναμίες τις οποίες ευτυχώς ακόμη δεν τις έχουμε στο κυπριακόμας γεσ
έναν από τα μεονεκτήματα του ελληνικού συστήματος είναι και οι συμπληρομί που